what is needed to fight terrorism books
and pens that's the claim of Malala
yousufzai the young 16 year old from
Pakistan received her sakharov prize
from the President of the European
Parliament the prize is celebrating its
25th year some 20 former recipients of
the prestigious award came together for
the occasion the European Parliament was
on its feet to applaud Malala activist
for the right of young girls to
education targeted by Pakistan's Taliban
in 2012 she took to this European
platform to reassert to fight it is
alarming that 57 million children are
deprived of Education they cannot go to
school this must shake on conscious it
is hardly imagine a world without
education it's an issue which is age-old
as the European Parliament itself that
of the multiple working locations since
1979 Strasbourg has housed the plenary
sessions while meetings and committees
have taken place in Brussels it's a
state of affairs which was
rubber-stamped during the nineteen
ninety-two edinburgh summit for a number
of years it has been criticized for its
environmental impact and economic costs
reaching between 150 and 200 million
euros per year and now the chewing and
throwing is facing a new attack it's a
question of democracy and I think it's
absolutely but 500 million citizens
expect from us they elect us they really
don't understand that we are not free to
decide where we were when we were how we
work so that's what we are going to
change but cuts clean hertzmann doesn't
see things in the same light she has
gathered with fellow French army peas
with the intention of defending the
Strasbourg seeds treaties can't be
changed overnight settlement ensamble
der said construction olu parliament
ante todo los kill deliver las chivas
news nipa uncle Joseph to cove ok the
hooligans I opa-locka me co-led see
solution however an important step
forward has been made towards a single
seat
just fifteen percent of women hold
non-executive seats on Europe's top
company boards and the figure is as low
as three percent for senior management
positions MEP is are advocating greater
equality between men and women the aim
to ensure women occupy forty percent of
non-executive board seats in publicly
listed companies some consider this as a
scaled-down target but others consider
it a promising start amoeba high minimum
yo noguchi avec different on danse avec
different mentality a reality recois que
se sepa low tolerance ambition mess a
sufficient com LMO con esta como Declan
Shane posted